all right this should be fun uh my next
guest has been
gently skewering politics for decades
with his secret comedy weapon
ragtime piano music your parents
probably have some of his old records
like
the farce of july and dc
pu well earlier today i'm told he
performed at the presidential
inauguration please welcome
political song paradise tip rivers hey
tip
hello coden tip rivers reporting for
duty
hey and speaking of duty i think we can
all agree that something
stinks in our country right now don't
get me started
you are clever well that's exactly why i
can't wait to hear
your comedic take on the state of
politics using the power of
old-fashioned
piano music well i shall do my able best
why don't i begin with a classic
presidential tune with a twist okay this
sounds scandalous and fun let's hear it
and away we go hail to the chief we have
chosen for the nation
donald j trump ascending to his kingly
throne
hail to our king who'll incarcerate joe
biden
and give nobel prizes to kid rock and
roger stone
hooray for donald trump
[Laughter]
wait a minute i'm sorry you played that
song at president biden's inauguration
by no no no no don't be ridiculous conan
i would never participate in that
farce we've got to stop the steal i
performed that song at the inauguration
for donald trump's rightful second term
now wait a minute there was no
inauguration for president trump's
second term that didn't happen
oh yes yes there was a small gathering
of patriots uh conducted the ceremony
today at
white house paint supplies that's uh
across the street from the dildo factory
no i don't know the dildo factory and it
just sounds sad to me
oh it's not sad at all you know they
throw all of the imperfect and irregular
dildos in a large trash bin
outside and a lot of them are perfectly
fine okay
you're missing the point tip tip we've
talked about this before
we've never talked about the dildo
factory not the dildo
factory we've talked about your career
in the old days your songs were gentle
and fun
and they were they were less right wing
i see what you're saying you you uh you
wanted a song that isn't quite as
triggering for sensitive libs like
yourself is that what you're saying
a little little i i i dare not melt the
snowflake that is conan o'brien all
right
very funny no i just liked your old
stuff all right let's set all that aside
and conan i'll sing you a fun song just
like you like
conan are you a fan of history i am a
big history buff
well very good okay how about this a
song about our country's revolutionary
heroes you're gonna enjoy this
take it away and away we go
the heroes go marching to the top mega
mega the heroes break windows and shove
cops mega
man the heroes stormed the capital steps
to smear feces on pelosi's desk
and we salute their bravery
you know tip stop it the people who
stormed the capital weren't
revolutionary war heroes
they were criminals possibly domestic
terrorists
well conan you say tomato i say tamato
no it you can't honor those people with
that
song what are you high as a matter of
fact i am a little high
yes it's fair to point that out i
usually sing in a nice
tenor but today i seem to be going up
into an auto range
that's a little musical joke conan but
uh no i do understand what you're saying
you're
accusing me of using drugs but i'm happy
to say conan that i'm 100
drug free with the exception of an
occasional stool softener
and oh um an antipsychotic that i am
required to take as a result of a recent
court ruling but i don't always take it
all right uh tip that's clear that you
don't always take it and uh
i'll be honest with you uh i was a fan
of your old work now i'm worried about
you
i can read the room all right this is
not a big truth crowd
you like something uh soft and gentle
okay so just let me go out on a high
note i'll play you something right
do me a favor don't sing anything
political you have a political song
paradise on the show
and you don't want to hear anything well
i you know after i've heard your what
you're doing
now no i don't want to hear any of that
well that's fine
no problem at all how about this how
about this well
conan earth day is right around the
corner well no
it's in april so it's not right around
the corner this'll hold
how about a salute to the planet earth
which is
the only planet we currently live on
that's fair let's hear that
when away here we go happy earth day
to me happy earth day to you
happy earth day to the climate that's
controlled
by the jews right now get me started
no no no tip that is a real problem that
is we cannot have
any one group of people controlling the
weather
jewish people are not controlling the
weather that's insane tips
the weather controlling machine is in is
in a little compound just outside the
tel aviv that's
okay no you know whatever they want to
make it rain or
a wind storm or any weather you can
imagine that's where it comes from yeah
we have a great show tonight ladies and
gentlemen i apologize for this idiot
max don't apologize max greenfield
you've created fog so they can hide when
they turn themselves into bats conan
they don't jewish people don't become
bats you idiot
yes of course they do they do not
max greenfield will be with us we'll be
right back and i apologize for this
[ __ ]
i apologize for conan no i apologize for
you
you look like a racist orville c
redenbacher what do you mean a racist
adorable see red locker he was pretty
racist
okay well that's now we've lost a
sponsor good job